bon allez on va compter cette fuite week
end avec notre invité du vendredi mirail
frésil bonjour donc je solidarités
nouvelles pour le logement
vous êtes en plateau avec nous pour
parler d'une animation qui a lieu samedi
et ça tombe bien j'ai envie de dire
c'est pas le mot est bien choisi mais en
tout cas ça tombe bien entre guillemets
puisque là au bon moment en tout cas
puisque la fondation abbé pierre vient
de rendre aujourd'hui vient de publier
son rapport sur le mal-logement en
france il ya un constat 3 8 6 millions
d'habitants sont non ou mal logés et
plus de 5 millions en france sont
fragilisées par la crise du logement
alors un mot d'abord sur votre
association solidarité nouvelles pour le
logement
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
qu'est-ce que vous faites alors
solidarités nouvelles pour le logement
est une association qui travaille sur
cinq départements dans la région dans
l'île de france et qui a pour objectif
de créer des logements dans le milieu
naturel c'est-à-dire pas ne pas les
mettre à l'exclusion or dégivre dans les
dents livre dans les voilà de créer des
logements soient soient regroupées soit
et unique individuel de l'est de les
louer à des personnes en grande
difficulté donc toutes les personnes qui
sont sur les listes de la préfecture
bien sûr dépendant de la loi dalo la
plupart du temps elles proposent un
accompagnement à la fois par une équipe
de professionnels qui se trouve au siège
de l'association au chesnay et par les
bénévoles des groupes locaux
ces personnes là vous les choisissez il
ya une sélection qui a fait non heroes
sélection près les dossiers on n'a pas
prévu on ne peut plus choisir enfin si
dans la mesure où on avait pu choisir
mais en général ce sont des listes qui
sont donnés par la préfecture
et il ya des commissions d'attribution
qui règle le l'attribution des logements
dont vous louez à ces personnes là on
doit ces personnels
vous êtes caution en quelque sorte on
peut dire qu'on est caution oui on est
caution parce que c'est en les servant
de vannes le temps nécessaire pour
qu'ils aient un logement à eux le
document durable donc il ya tout un
travail avec les bailleurs pour l'or
lors faire qui est une confiance
réciproque entre les bailleurs et snl et
quel est le coût de la location est ce
que c'est de la location de local pour
les locataires
c'est un cours classique l'avait plutôt
à la banane on s'éteint c'est un petit
lolo loyer mais un loyer qui est définie
par les pouvoirs publics
je crois que c'est de l'ordre de 6 euros
le mètre carré saison le mètre carré
je me rends pas compte ben 10 6 euros le
mètre carré si le moins cher possible
ah oui là dessus il peut tolérer ça me
remet en question le chemin d'accord ok
donc c'est plutôt un prix c'est un autre
guillemets puisque oui c'est un plus
très adaptée à leur situation était tout
à fait votre association acquis le 18
juillet 2012
un logement de 61 mètres carrés dans le
quartier de la grande île à voisin
brummitt tristement des familles en
difficulté donc expliquer nous alors
vous acheter des logements en achètent
un logement 25% du coût du logement
revient aux bénévoles de l'association
donc c'est énorme donc ça veut dire que
sont les bénévoles qui vont payer les 25
pour soit absolument alors là vous avez
choisi un vous à dire une ville pas la
plus pauvres ont tout de même une ville
bien côté de l'agglomération saint
quentinois ce qu'est
voisins-le-bretonneux donc ça veut dire
que le prix est quand même assez élevé
pour les bénévoles
tout à fait c'est très élevé donc on a
fait appel à dix une collecte de dons
régulièrement on sollicite les donateurs
qu'ils sont très généreux sur le secteur
et puis on organise des manifestations
non seulement pour obtenir de l'argent
mais aussi pour se faire connaître
alors j'ai développé notre notre notre
groupe local
on y arrive justement puisque samedi à
partir de 19h au centre alfred de vigny
à voisin boutonneux gala il ya un loto
gourmand 50,4 en juillet loto
gastronomique est organisée pour
justement collecter des fonds alors les
gens qui vont venir vont devoir payer 10
euros 10 euros l'entrée les temps et les
cartons pour ceux qui jouent au loto ce
qui réserve mais ce surplace ce sera
celle qui jouait taux seront ce que veut
dire un carton
la voix va pas expliquer par 6 10 euros
quatre cartons l'entrée et cet argent
sera reversé intégralement à réagir
l'association pour aider la casse
question de l'achat de cet affrontement
et savoir et puis comme ça commence à 19
heures il y aura un petit casse-croûte
aussi qui sera payant qui sera qui
reviendra aussi dans la caisse pour
acheter le logement et vous disais un
loto gastronomique parce que lorsque
nous avons nous avons sollicité les
restaurateurs qui ont et nous ont fait
un accueil extraordinaire on a 25
restaurants du secteur qui nous offre
deux repas gratuits
d'accord c'est formidable 25 c'est pas
mal aussi beaucoup ça veut dire que les
commerçants jouent vraiment là oui ils
ont vraiment très bien on a été très
bien accueillie très très bien ça on les
remercie infiniment vous on est très
bien accueilli parce que vous avez
l'impression que la thématique de
logements la thématique de la solidarité
quand on va à toquer aux portes d'un
restaurateur d'un commerçant sa porte
tout à fait tout à fait ils sont très
sensibles si vous voulez ya eu tellement
de de commander le documentaire sur le
mal logement qu'ils sont forcément
sensible à cette situation et donc ils
nous ont vraiment bien accueilli
nous avons vu que notre loto était
vraiment une bonne idée je reviens
justement puisque vous dites fragilisées
par problématique par le manque de
logement quand on vous rend compte on
lille rapport d'aller pierre qu'on voit
que 5 millions effectivement de français
sont fragilisées dans le populisme est
un peu plus sont fragilisés est-ce que
vous en auto sein de votre association
saint quentin est du snl est ce que vous
leur santé
est ce que c'est en progression les
demandes ah oui j'ai demandé il ya un
effet malheureusement j'ai envie de dire
crise
oui oui tout à fait tout à fait il ya
une très nette augmentation de demandes
quand on va dans les municipalités leur
demandait le nombre de dossiers qu'ils
me demandent ces énormes ils peuvent vie
peuvent pas fait ils peuvent pas fournir
c'est pas possible
combien de familles vous avez aidé à
sociale l'association lama et des 11100
je crois on se sent en 2011 en ce sens
depuis elle a beaucoup plus mais ça
c'est sûr toute la région parisienne
mais quel type de profil les familles
parce que c'est des femmes par exemple
des gens vivent parental
coût de plus en plus aux parental dvd
femme seule avec deux enfants ou deux
enfants des couples un peu qu'ils
perdent leur emploi enfin voyez tout ce
que cela entraîne tous que la crise
entraîne la perte d'emploi perte de lien
social souvent perte de repères de la
médialle familiaux et puis
malheureusement l'enchaînement est
terrible perte de logement etc
comment comment l'association est
financée alors donc 25 % ce sont les
bénévoles assez importante sur les
bénévoles
le reste c'est les des subventions qui
viennent des municipalités pour nous
c'est l'agglomération qui nous a qui
nous a subventionné à l'heure de 29
mille euros quelque chose comme ça et
puis on fait des demandes pour à toutes
les eaux qu'au conseil régional le
conseil général non ne donne pas
d'accord chacun chacun songe et soulevé
une polémique
non non non ça c'est pas une politique
c'est une question de structure d'accord
si vous voulez la conseil régional et
puis des subventions de la vespière les
subventions de la fondation de france et
tout ça et toutes ces subventions ne
sont ne sont alloués que si nous notre
logement est conforme aux
réglementations environnementales alors
ça c'est très compliqué parce que notre
logement vous voyez il a été acheté il
ne pourra accueillir quelqu'un qu'en
septembre
parce qu'il faut faire des travaux et
que tant que c'est pour la mise aux
normes environnement pas voilà d'accord
pour pas qu'il soit coûteux en énergie
exactement c'est très intéressant pour
les locataires parce que ils auront peu
de chaleur des travaux à faire pour
douce et des travaux à faire et les
subventions sont en diminution où elle
reste stable
ah oui à des diminutions pour le
fonctionnement de l'association d'aidé
grosse diminution on a un gros problème
pour faire fonctionner l'association au
niveau du département
d'accord donc ça veut dire que vous
faites aussi un appel ah oui à la
pénalisation à la générosité en la
générosité pour faire fonctionner la
société rien que pour faire fonctionner
son signal
d'accord merci beaucoup à réfléchir sur
le bateau 17,8 week-end est donc je
rappelle ce loto gastronomique est
proposée samedi donc 2 février à partir
de 19 heures au centre alfred de vigny
de voisins-le-bretonneux voilà si vous
voulez venir en aide financièrement à
l'association solidarités nouvelles pour
le logement est un type dans mercy et
puis vous pouvez aussi faire des dons
supplémentaires merci beaucoup mais avec
l'âge il